If you're like me, you know this feeling. Maybe you're at a party or you're walking down the street. And suddenly, out of a sea of passing faces, one of them lights up looking right at you. This person starts waving, says hello. This person is glad to see you. And you, you have no idea who you're looking at. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vitaanthan. Today on the show, we're talking about faces. Recognizing faces is a crucial skill. It's so crucial that there are regions of the brain
如果你跟我一样，你一定懂这种感觉。也许你在派对上，或者正走在街上。突然，在擦肩而过的人海中，有一张脸亮了起来，正看着你。这个人开始挥手，向你打招呼。这个人很高兴见到你。而你，根本不知道自己看到的是谁。这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。今天的节目中，我们来聊聊面孔。认出面孔是一项至关重要的技能。它如此重要，以至于大脑中有专门负责面部识别的区域。
devoted to facial recognition. But although your mind is amazing at identifying your boyfriend or your child in a crowd, there are important limits to this ability. Some of us, like me, are extremely bad at it. Some of us are terrific. On today's show, we look at some people who are on opposite ends of the spectrum and talk about how our ability to recognize faces has broad implications in our lives. We'll start with someone whose job requires her to be quick with faces. She's a cop. My name is Alison Young and I'm a place of so-and-a-much for a place in London.
但尽管你的大脑在人群中识别出你的男朋友或孩子时表现得惊人，这种能力还是有重要局限的。我们中的一些人，比如我，在这方面极其糟糕。而我们中的一些人则非常厉害。在今天的节目中，我们将探讨处于光谱两端的一些人，并讨论我们识别面孔的能力对我们的生活产生的广泛影响。我们将从一个工作需要她快速识别面孔的人开始。她是一名警察。我叫艾莉森·杨，我是伦敦的一名……
She started out several years ago working on response teams in East London. These are the cops who mostly just respond to 911 calls. Then, about three and a half years into that job, she and a bunch of her fellow officers were invited to take a series of tests at a university. You get given like three or four different faces and you have to memorize those faces. Then a new screen appears with other faces. These ones are obscured in some way, or heavily pixelated. One of the faces you saw earlier might now show up wearing a beard. So you have to try and work out which one of the faces is the face that you've seen before,
几年前，她开始在伦敦东部的应急小队工作。这些警察主要负责处理911报警电话。然后，在大约三年半的工作后，她和许多同事受邀去一所大学参加了一系列测试。给你看三四张不同的面孔，你必须记住这些面孔。接着会弹出一个新屏幕，显示其他面孔。这些面孔在某种程度上被遮挡了，或者高度像素化。你之前看到的一张面孔现在可能会戴上胡子出现。所以你必须设法找出哪一张面孔是你以前见过的面孔，
and it's that kind of thing. The test, of course, was measuring how good officers were at recognizing faces. A while later, Alison received her results. She came in second out of all the officers. And they asked me to come down to Scotland, you're odd. Scotland, you're out, of course, is the headquarters for London police. When she got there, she was told she was being added
诸如此类的事情。当然，这个测试是为了衡量警官们识别面孔的能力有多强。不久后，艾莉森收到了她的成绩。她在所有警官中名列第二。他们让我去苏格兰场。苏格兰场当然是伦敦警察总部。她到达那里后，被告知她将被加入
to a new unit they were forming. It was called the Super Recognizer Unit. Yes, that's what that's the name that they've given. Do you feel like a Super Recognizer? I don't know, I don't, well I guess so, but I don't think I'd necessarily say that a lot because it's just worth super isn't it? It just sounds a bit super. I don't know, just the notion of the word super, it kind of brings out as if where some sort of super hero or something like that, That isn't the case. Here's how the Super Recognizer Unit works. This pool of cops with above average abilities to recognize faces sits in front of computers.
他们正在组建的一个新单位。它被称为“超级识别者”单位。是的，这就是他们起的名字。你觉得自己是个“超级识别者”吗？我不知道，我……嗯，我想是的，但我不认为我一定会经常这么说，因为“超级”这个词本身就很那个，不是吗？听起来有点太夸张了。我不知道，“超级”这个词的概念，它有点让人觉得好像我们是什么超级英雄之类的，事实并非如此。“超级识别者”单位的工作方式如下。这群具备高于平均水平的面部识别能力的警察坐在电脑前。
They have faces of criminal suspects shown to them and they try, in essence, to play a matching game. Well, they're the catalog of criminals, essentially, that are wanted by colleagues. And what they decided to develop was a thing called snapping which meant that we may not know who that person is but if I look at this face number one photo on this chart and then I continue to go through further and further and further through different photos can I find him in any other photos that he's wanted for, which then means that we've got him for one offense of, I don't know, theft. We find him for another offense to do his theft.
他们面前显示着犯罪嫌疑人的面孔，他们本质上是在玩一个配对游戏。嗯，他们本质上是同事们通缉的罪犯名录。他们决定开发的一项功能叫做“捕捉”，这意味着我们可能不知道那个人是谁，但如果我看着这张图表上的第一张照片，然后继续在一张又一张不同的照片中不断查找，我能在与他被通缉的其他罪犯照片中找到他吗？这意味着我们可以以某项罪行（比如我不知道的盗窃罪）抓获他。我们可以因另一项与盗窃有关的罪行找到他。
And you end up accruing this one person for around 25 to 30 different times. Now, computers are getting better at this kind of task. And maybe one day algorithms will come to replace human beings in making these kinds of matches for police. But for now, Scotland Yard decided to put its faith in humans like Alison. That's because there are some things that humans can do that computers can't. Last year, for example, the transit police came to Scotland to out for help. A 21-year-old woman and two girls aged 15 and 16 complained that a man had inappropriately
最后你可能会发现同一个人犯了大约25到30次不同的罪行。现在，电脑在处理这类任务时正变得越来越好。也许有一天，算法会取代人类来为警方进行这种匹配。但目前，苏格兰场决定信任像艾莉森这样的人类。这是因为有些事情人类能做到，而电脑做不到。例如，去年交通警察来到苏格兰场寻求帮助。一名21岁的女子和两名分别为15岁和16岁的女孩投诉说，一名男子在乘公交车时对她们进行了不当触摸。
touched them while riding the bus. Transit police pulled security footage taken from the various buses. From the pictures and the witness accounts, it appeared his modus operandi was to get on the bus with the newspaper. He would sit next to the young woman and then attempt to fondle her under cover of the newspaper. And they were overtly young in their respect that some of the Murn school uniformed. The security footage was grainy.
交通警察调取了来自不同公交车的监控录像。从照片和证人陈述来看，他的作案手法似乎是带着一份报纸上车。他会坐在年轻女子旁边，然后在报纸的掩护下试图抚摸她。从他们的某些方面来看，他们明显还很年轻，其中一些还穿着学校制服。监控录像画面很模糊。
The transit police didn't have an ID on the man. And because he struck at different times on different buses, they didn't know how to track him down. And they basically had said to us, we need to find this man. It's young girls, it's predatory, etc. So myself and my colleague, Texas Sergeant Elliott Porreck, like did some investigation. They studied the security videos, and eventually they figured out which station the man tended to frequent. We discovered that he had quite a specific route of generally being around Camden Town,
交通警察没有那名男子的身份证信息。而且由于他在不同的时间、不同的公交车上作案，他们不知道如何追踪他。他们基本上对我们说：“我们需要找到这个男人。受害者是年轻女孩，这是掠夺性行为，等等。”于是我和我的同事、警长埃利奥特·波雷克进行了一些调查。他们研究了监控视频，最终找出了这名男子经常光顾的车站。我们发现他有一条相当特定的路线，通常在卡姆登镇附近活动，
which is an area in northwest London. Camden Town is a busy neighbourhood. It's heavily populated with lots of shops and tourists and people always milling about. It's perfect in other words for someone to blend into the background. Alison and Elliot Poret knew what they had to do. So we made our way to Camden Town. From Scotland Yard, on a Wednesday, a current under the exact date, but I know it was a Wednesday.
这是伦敦西北部的一个区域。卡姆登镇是一个繁忙的街区。这里人口稠密，有许多商店和游客，人们总是四处闲逛。换句话说，这里非常适合某人融入背景。艾莉森和埃利奥特·波雷克知道他们必须做什么。于是我们前往卡姆登镇。从苏格兰场出发，在星期三，我不记得确切日期了，但我知道那是星期三。
This was supposed to be just a scouting mission to get a sense of the Camdentown bus station. Allison and her partner decided to look through all security footage in the CCTV rule. So we went to the CCTV bit, which was just behind a clear, per-spec glass, where people buy their tickets. So it's right by the entrance for a tube station. Detective Porid began talking with the transit security. Allison was looking through the glass at the commuters milling about the station. Detective Porid began talking with the transit security. Allison was looking through the glass at the commuters milling about the station. I just glanced up and through the crowd.
这本应该只是一次侦察任务，旨在熟悉卡姆登镇公交车站的情况。艾莉森和她的搭档决定查看监控室里的所有监控录像。于是我们去了监控室，它就在售票处透明有机玻璃的后面。所以它就在地铁站入口旁边。波雷克侦探开始与交通安保人员交谈。艾莉森透过玻璃看着在车站闲逛的通勤者。波雷克侦探开始与交通安保人员交谈。艾莉森透过玻璃看着在车站闲逛的通勤者。我只是抬头向人群中看去。
I just saw him. I saw him walk in, pick up a newspaper and leave. I will go to leave and at which point I, I mean I screamed because I don't know why I did it. I just screamed. I just thought I don't know, I can't quite work out why. But I just made quite loud noise and just said to Sergeant Porrette, he's outside. They both stopped what they were doing and rushed to catch up with the man. But it was quite difficult to get out because we had to go all the way back round, back round to the FOIA. So by the time we'd got into the main FOIA where he was,
我一眼就看到了他。我看着他走进来，拿了一份报纸然后离开。我正要离开，就在那一刻，我——我的意思是，我尖叫了，因为我不知道自己为什么要这么做。我只是尖叫了。我只是想——我不知道，我有点说不清楚原因。但我发出了挺大的声音，对波雷克警长说：“他在外面。”他们俩停下手中的活，冲过去追赶那个人。但要出去相当困难，因为我们必须一路绕回去，绕回门厅。所以等我们进入他所在的中央门厅时，
we couldn't see him anymore. They ran out of the station to see if he'd left. They looked left, couldn't see him. They looked right. Alison caught a quick glimpse of a man disappearing around a corner. This fraction of a second was all a man disappearing around the corner. This fraction of a second was all she needed to recognize her target. The cops started running toward the corner. And as we turned, we looked just behind the wall, it was there. The officers approached the man.
我们就再也看不到他了。他们跑出车站，看他是否已经离开。他们向左看，没看到他。他们向右看。艾莉森匆忙瞥见一个男子在拐角处消失。这短短的一瞬间，就是男子在拐角处消失的全部情景。这短短的一瞬间，正是她认出目标所需要的全部时间。警察开始朝拐角跑去。当我们转过弯时，朝墙后面一看，他就在那里。警官们走近那男子。
As soon as we got up to him, I didn't fight to fight with him. The paragraph about myself, Detective Sergeant Porick, we were a hundred million percent certain that this was the exact same gentleman in all the photos. So he was fighting handcuffs immediately and explained to him what it was being arrested for, etc. And it was extremely noticeable that he was very nervous, his mouth just went completely dry. And he just wasn't able to speak. The man was recently sentenced to prison and is suspended from using London's public transit
我们一走到他跟前，我并没有跟他发生争执。关于我自己和埃利奥特·波雷克警长，我们百分之百确切地认为这就是所有照片中一模一样的那个绅士。所以他立即戴上了手铐，并向他解释了他被逮捕的原因等等。非常明显的是，他非常紧张，嘴巴干得厉害。而且他根本说不出话来。这名男子最近被判处监禁，并且在刑满释放后被禁止使用伦敦的公共交通。
after he's released. Alison Young no longer works on the super recognizer unit. She has gone on to other detective work, but she says the time she spent on this unusual unit was the first she ever realised she had an above average ability. The thing is, she is still not sure where the skill comes from. I think my mum was just like, oh you have that from me, modest as ever, my mother. My mum is very, very, very good with faces, very good. We're walking, just doing some shopping, and she'll see someone and go and speak to them.
艾莉森·杨不再在“超级识别者”单位工作了。她已经转向了其他的侦探工作，但她说，她在苏格兰场这个不同寻常的单位度过的时间，是她第一次意识到自己拥有高于平均水平的能力。问题是，她仍然不确定这项技能是从哪里来的。我觉得我妈妈当时就像是：“哦，你是从我这继承的这能力，”我妈妈一如既往地谦虚。我妈妈认脸非常非常厉害，非常厉害。我们在散步，只是顺便买点东西，她就会看到某个人并走过去跟他们说话。
And she'll have known them from primary school, and she'll remember them. And my mum's watching our 61, and she went to primary School like seven or eight with them and she'll remember them. So do you think this is genetic or do you think this is learned? I don't know, I don't think you could teach someone. I don't think you could teach someone to be able to I call. Coming up, how come in a zealousant skill? Are you a super recognizer? Can you learn to be one? That and more from a scientist who studies how we identify faces. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. So the other week I was at the airport and just like everyone else, I showed my driver's
而且她能从小学就认出他们，她会记得他们。我妈妈今年61岁了，她大概七八岁时就跟他们上同一所小学，她居然还记得他们。所以你认为这是基因决定的，还是后天习得的？我不知道，我不认为你能教别人。我不认为你能教别人去拥有——我称之为天赋。接下来，这种惊人的技能是如何产生的？你是一个超级识别者吗？你能通过学习成为一个超级识别者吗？这些以及更多内容将由一位研究我们如何识别人脸的科学家为您解答。这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。上周我在机场，和大家一样，我出示了驾照
license to get past security. And it occurred to me that I was operating on an assumption that I think is widely shared. I assumed the TSA officer was pretty good at matching my face with the photo on my driver's license. So I asked Mike Burton, he's a professor of psychology at the University of York in the United Kingdom, if that assumption was true. It's not, although it is a very common assumption, most of us think we're pretty good at recognizing faces,
来通过安检。我突然意识到，我的操作基于一个我认为被广泛认同的假设。我假设TSA（运输安全管理局）的工作人员非常擅长将我的脸与驾照上的照片进行匹配。于是我问迈克·伯顿，他是英国约克大学的心理学教授，这个假设是否属实。事实并非如此，尽管这是一个非常普遍的假设，我们大多数人都认为自己相当擅长识别人脸，
but when you actually test people out, particularly in the situation where someone who doesn't know you is checking a photo against you, it turns out people are really bad at this. Interestingly, even professionals are really bad at it, so we did some work with passport officers last year, where we showed that even passport officers find this a very difficult task and are often inaccurate. When I showed my ID at the airport last week, Mike, I had it over the ID and I noticed that the officer looked at the ID first and then looked at my face second and I assumed there must be some trick to this that it actually is you're able to make a better connection
但当你真正对人们进行测试时，尤其是在一个不认识你的人拿照片与你本人进行核对的情境下，结果证明人们在这方面真的很糟糕。有趣的是，甚至专业人员也很糟糕，所以我们去年与护照官员合作做了一些工作，我们发现即使是护照官员也觉得这是一项非常困难的任务，而且往往不够准确。迈克，上周我在机场出示身份证时，我把身份证递过去，我注意到工作人员先看了身份证，然后才看我的脸，我以为这其中一定有什么诀窍，那就是如果你不先看这个人的脸，而是从身份证开始看，然后再看脸，
if you don't actually look at the person's face that you start with the ID and then look at the face. Is there any truth to that? No, there's all kinds of techniques that the people who do this professionally use. And what's interesting is they all believe themselves to be performing quite well. But when you test them, just like anybody else, they're actually not very accurate at this.
实际上能够做出更好的关联。这有什么道理吗？没有，从事这项专业工作的人使用了各种各样的技术。有趣的是，他们都相信自己表现得相当不错。但当你测试他们时，就像其他人一样，他们在这方面的准确率其实并不高。
It's a little terrifying what you're telling me because you're saying that this thing that we're relying on to keep ourselves safe to run security systems at airports and other places, that this is a fundamentally bad system? That is exactly what I'm telling you. I think that what's sort of interesting is that we have come to rely on this, but I think we've come to rely on it for an interesting reason. We are fantastic at recognising faces, those faces of people we know, we can recognise our family and friends across a huge range of conditions, you know, at distances in bad light all kinds. But we falsely assume that this means we're quite good at faces in general, and in fact we're not.
你告诉我的这些有点让人恐慌，因为你是说我们依赖于保障自身安全、运行机场和其他地方安检系统的这个东西，本质上是一个糟糕的系统？这正是我要告诉你的。我觉得有点意思的是，我们已经开始依赖它了，但我认为我们开始依赖它有一个有趣的原因。我们极其擅长识别人脸，也就是我们认识的人的面孔，我们能够在各种各样的条件下认出我们的家人和朋友，你知道，在远距离、光线不好的情况下以及各种情况下。但我们错误地认为，这意味着我们在总体上也相当擅长辨认面孔，而事实上我们并非如此。
Mike can say all this with some degree of confidence because he ran a study to test for it. So we set up this little experiment where we asked people to match pairs of faces. They just have to say, are these two faces the same person or not? Mike and his colleagues ran this experiment in both the United Kingdom and in Australia. In both countries, they selected some faces that were likely to be well-known locally, but unlikely to be known globally. Yes, we use what we call be lists celebrities, so we check it out before I had, but we use people who are known very well by the local population.
迈克之所以能相当自信地得出这些结论，是因为他进行了一项测试研究。于是我们设计了这个小实验，要求人们匹配成对的面孔。他们只需要说，这两张面孔是同一个人还是不同的人？迈克和他的同事在英国和澳大利亚都进行了这项实验。在两个国家，他们都选择了一些在当地可能广为人知，但在全球范围内不太可能被知道的面孔。是的，我们使用了所谓的B级名人，所以我们在事前进行了核对，但我们使用的是当地居民非常熟悉的人。
These are people like newsreaders, local sports people, and they tend to be very well known by the local community, but not by people internationally. What we find then is that when the UK people are matching UK celebrities, they're really good at it. And they're really poor at matching the Australian celebrities, the people that they don't know. When you look at the Australian students looking at these photos, you find exactly the opposite pattern. They're great at matching Australian celebrities and poor at matching UK celebrities. So at this point, we know that there's nothing in the faces themselves that
这些人就像是新闻主播、当地的体育明星，他们往往被当地社区所熟知，但国际上的人并不认识。然后我们发现，当英国人匹配英国名人时，他们真的非常擅长。而他们在匹配澳大利亚名人——那些他们不认识的人时，表现真的很差。当你看到澳大利亚学生看这些照片时，你会发现完全相反的模式。他们非常擅长匹配澳大利亚名人，而在匹配英国名人时则很差。所以在这一点上，我们知道面孔本身并没有什么特点
make them easy or hard to match. It's just in the perceptions of the viewers. So far so good we know that people are better at matching familiar faces. But what we then ask is how well do you think other people will do on these faces when we give them the same task? And what you find is that the UK viewers think other people will find the UK faces easier, the Australian viewers think other people will find the Australian photos easier. That can't both be true. It must be that they are falsely generalising their own knowledge to other people. You make a very interesting point in the paper, and I was struck by it, which is that in
让它们变得容易或难以匹配。这只在于观察者的认知。到目前为止一切顺利，我们知道人们更擅长匹配熟悉的面孔。但我们随后要问的是，当我们给其他人同样的任务时，你认为其他人对这些面孔的表现会怎样？你会发现，英国的观众认为其他人会觉得英国的面孔更容易，澳大利亚的观众认为其他人会觉得澳大利亚的照片更容易。这两者不可能都是真的。一定是因为他们错误地将自己的知识推广到了其他人身上。你在论文中提出了一个非常有趣的观点，让我印象深刻，那就是在
some ways this might be part of a general phenomenon in cognition where we do not fully understand how difficult a task is for someone else to do, and especially when we are good at something, it's very, very difficult for us to anticipate how much harder it could be for somebody else to do the very same task. That's right. It comes up in a number of areas of psychology, even something simple like general knowledge. If you happen to have read some books about Napoleon and be knowledgeable about Napoleon, you falsely generalise that and assume that other people know more about
某些方面，这可能是认知中普遍现象的一部分，即我们并不完全理解一项任务对别人来说有多困难，尤其是当我们擅长某事时，我们非常非常难以预料，对于其他人来说，做完全相同的任务可能会难得多。没错。这在心理学的许多领域都会出现，甚至像常识这样简单的事情也是如此。如果你恰好读过一些关于拿破仑的书并且对拿破仑很了解，你就会错误地将其推广，并假设其他人对
Napoleon than they actually do. Of course, we all have our own different areas of specialist knowledge. And people turn out to be rather poor at understanding that and being able to generalise it. I'm wondering how good you are at facial recognition. I'm poor. On the tests I'm just a little below average. And doing these tests and studying this has it sort of changed the way you yourself trust yourself or your ability to recognize faces? Well, I do now know how poor I am. I certainly would try not to rely on my own ability to do it. But I think that nobody really knew until the last few years just how bad we all are with unfamiliar faces.
拿破仑的了解比他们实际知道的要多。当然，我们每个人都有自己不同的专业知识领域。事实证明，人们在理解这一点并能够将其普遍化方面相当糟糕。我想知道你在面部识别方面有多擅长？我很差。在测试中，我只是略低于平均水平。进行这些测试和研究是否改变了你自己信任自己或识别人脸能力的方式？嗯，我现在确实知道自己有多差了。我当然会尽量不依赖自己在这方面的能力。但我认为，直到最近几年，大家才真正知道我们所有人对不熟悉的面孔有多么糟糕。
And it's just becoming clear now. Our chronic inability to recognize faces, coupled with our chronic overconfidence in our ability to recognize faces, has big consequences. One place that's especially true is in the criminal justice system, where eyewitness identifications are often central to police investigations. But this issue also shows up in lots of other settings with lower stakes, recognizing colleagues at an office party or a fellow parent at a school meeting. Julie Dorschlag from Washington, DC has had this problem for a long time. I've had a lot of uncomfortable situations for getting people and have been accused of being a snob or racist or I mean everything.
现在才刚刚变得明朗。我们长期无法识别人脸，再加上我们对识别人脸能力的长期过度自信，带来了巨大的后果。这种现象尤其明显的一个地方是刑事司法系统，那里目击者的辨认往往是警方调查的核心。但这个问题也出现在许多其他风险较低的场合，比如在办公室派对上认出同事，或在学校家长会上认出其他家长。来自华盛顿特区的朱莉·多施拉格长期以来一直面临这个问题。我经历过很多尴尬的情况，因为记不住人而被指责为势利、种族主义，或者说我什么都有。
If Allison Young, the copy heard from earlier, was a super recognizer, you might call Julie Faceblind. Her whole life, she's been terrible with faces. When I was in college, you're on a campus, you meet a lot of people all the time. And there were people I met for a few minutes at a party or something, a meeting, I don't know. And I'd be on campus, a small campus, walking, and I'd walk past them.
如果前面提到的那个警察艾莉森·杨是个超级识别者，你可能会称朱莉为“面孔失认症”患者。她一辈子对人脸都很不在行。当我在大学时，你在校园里，你一直会遇到很多人。有些人在派对或别的什么地方、某个会议上我见了几分钟，我不知道。我会走在校园里，一个小校园，走着走着，我就会从他们身边走过。
Didn't think anything of it. Just smile and keep going. And they were offended. I've heard over time, people were offended. I got this little reputation of being this snobby person because I didn't greet everybody that I met or how are you doing. So, and normally would if I knew them or I thought I knew them. Julie struggles followed her as she left college and entered the working world. I worked for an architecture firm in Philadelphia and we had to go to a meeting and I swore
完全没当回事。只是笑笑然后继续走。而他们被冒犯了。随着时间的推移，我听说人们被冒犯了。我落得了一个势利眼的坏名声，因为我没有跟我遇到的每个人打招呼，也没有问“你最近怎么样”。所以，如果我认识他们或者我以为我认识他们，我通常会打招呼的。朱莉的挣扎在她离开大学进入职场后依然伴随着她。我在费城的一家建筑事务所工作，我们需要去开个会，我发誓
after going into the meeting and then coming back going back into the meeting room, I talked to this guy as if I knew him, he happened to be African-American and I was talking to him. He's like, I'm not that man. I said, I'm sorry. I could have sworn. He's like, oh, okay. So it became that. And it's not, it's not people of just color or different ethnicity. What do you do about it? I apologize profusely and usually the people just walk away from me. So I just stop. I just feel embarrassed. I'm just used to being embarrassed.
在走进会议室又走出来、然后再次回到会议室后，我跟这个家伙说话的语气就好像我认识他一样，他碰巧是个非裔美国人，我在跟他说话。他说：“我不是那个人。”我说：“对不起。”我敢发誓是的。他说：“哦，好吧。”事情就变成了这样。而且这不仅限于某种肤色或不同种族的人。你对此能做些什么呢？我深表歉意，通常人们就会直接走开。所以我干脆停下来。我只是觉得尴尬。我已经习惯了尴尬。
Research suggests, by the way, that people are worse at recognizing faces of people from unfamiliar groups. Many Americans are worse at recognizing the face of someone from a different race than a face of someone from their own race. Now, what makes Julie's dilemma especially acute is her husband, Marty. When I look at somebody, I never forget their face. If I spend about 30 seconds looking at somebody, I will remember their face for years and years
顺便说一句，研究表明，人们在识别人熟悉程度较低群体的人的面孔时表现更差。许多美国人在识别不同种族的人的面孔时，表现得比识别自己种族的人的面孔更差。现在，让朱莉的困境尤为严峻的是她的丈夫马蒂。当我看着某个人时，我永远不会忘记他们的脸。如果我花大约30秒钟看着某个人，我会记住他的脸好几年
and years. Marty Doshlag, Julie's husband, is a super recognizer. For years, Julie's been keenly aware of her husband's superpower. One time they were in Las Vegas sitting down for dinner at a restaurant, Marty clandestapped at the waiter. He's like, oh, you waited on me in Columbus, Ohio, and X year, the guy just froze. And then he's like, oh yeah, and I don't know how you put it together, you named the restaurant, the time, the place.
甚至很多年。马蒂·多施拉格，朱莉的丈夫，是一个超级识别者。多年来，朱莉一直深深地意识到她丈夫的这种超能力。有一次他们在拉斯维加斯的一家餐厅坐下来吃晚餐，马蒂突然走向服务员。他说：“哦，你在俄亥俄州哥伦布市接待过我，在某某年，”那家伙直接愣住了。然后他说：“哦，对啊，”我不知道你是怎么把这些拼凑起来的，你连餐厅、时间和地点都说出来了。
And it was probably 15 years before. And he said, yeah, you're right. And so he does it a lot with servers and I think people in restaurant industry travel and he remembers them because they're server, you see their face. Marty said lots of encounters like this. Like at the Dallas airport, he spotted a man he sat behind at a University of Michigan football game three years earlier. Now, you might think that with this gift, Marty could at least be Julie's crutch,
而且那可能已经是15年前的事了。那人说：“对，你说得对。”所以他经常对服务员这样做，我想餐饮业的人经常旅行，他能记住他们，因为他们是服务员，你看过他们的脸。马蒂有过很多这样的遭遇。比如在达拉斯机场，他认出了一个三年前曾在密歇根大学橄榄球比赛中坐在他身后的人。现在，你可能会认为有了这个天赋，马蒂至少可以成为朱莉的拐杖，
but it doesn't always work out like that. If we're in a place, I'll always, sometimes, and I whisper in the back of the rear, that's Jim, who works at it, so and so. Well, sometimes he doesn't catch me in time. I think we were at one of your friends' apartments. A guy came in and I went up and hugged him and said, oh, it's so good to see you again. And Marty's friend, Lindoverin, said,
但事情并不总是那样发展。如果我们去某个地方，我总是——有时我会小声在后面嘀咕，那是吉姆，他在某某公司上班。嗯，有时他没能及时接住我的话。我想我们当时在你的某个朋友的公寓里。一个家伙走进来，我走过去拥抱了他，说：“哦，很高兴再次见到你。”马蒂的朋友琳达·沃伦说：
why is Julie hugging the caterer? So yeah. Oh, yeah. Yeah. I remember that too. And I thought that was funny. But I saw it coming, too. I saw Julie approaching the guy.
“为什么朱莉要拥抱餐饮服务员？”所以，是的。哦，是的。对。我也记得那个。而且我觉得那挺搞笑的。但我其实也预料到了。我看到朱莉朝那个人走过去。
And I said to my friend, I said, watch, she's going to think that's your roommate. Because they look sort of a, they look, I mean, they had the same color hair, I think, or something. And they were the same size. And I said to him, here it comes, watch. And sure enough, she did it. It was,
我对我的朋友说：“看，她会以为那是你的室友。”因为他们看起来有点——他们看起来，我是说，我想他们有相同的发色或者别的什么。而且他们的体型一样。我对他说：“来了，看吧。”果不其然，她真的这么做了。那真是，
but I touched him, I hugged him. So that big, that goes into another. You have to be careful. Oh. Julie's cringe-worthy ordeals hit close to home. Recently, I was watching a play. The lead actor looked familiar. I stared at his face for the better part of 90 minutes, but it took me until after the play was over to realise this was a colleague of mine from NPR.
但我碰了他，我拥抱了他。所以这，这就又牵扯到另一件事。你必须小心。哦。朱莉那些令人尴尬的遭遇就发生在身边。最近，我在看一出戏。主演看起来很面熟。我盯着他的脸看了差不多90分钟，直到演出结束后，我才意识到这是我在NPR的一位同事。
I'd be absolutely terrible as a TSA agent. And I got me wondering, are there any solutions here? Julie's picked a simple one. I don't approach people with as much jua to viva. I don't touch them until I'm sure they want to be touched. And I know them. And also, I sort of create this verbal cue for them to tell me why I know them. So if I shake their hand, I'll say, oh, right.
如果让我当TSA安检员，我绝对糟糕透顶。这让我想知道，这里有什么解决办法吗？朱莉选择了一个简单的办法。我不再满腔热情地接近别人。在确信他们希望被拥抱之前，我不会拥抱他们。而且我得认识他们。另外，我会在某种程度上为他们创造一个语言提示，让他们告诉我为什么我认识他们。所以如果我跟他们握手，我会说：“哦，对了。
Do I know you from somewhere? And they're like, if they say, I don't think so. I said, OK, you just looked a little familiar. I'd rather err on that side than not knowing them. And if they finish the sentence, I said, yes, that's right. Good to see you again. But I don't use again until I know that they've filled in the blank. For many thousands of years, humans lived in small, nomadic groups.
我是不是在哪里见过你？”如果他们说：“我想没有吧。”我会说：“好的，你看起来有点面熟。”我宁愿犯这种错，也不愿装作不认识他们。如果他们接上了话，我会说：“是的，没错。很高兴再次见到你。”但在他们把空白填上之前，我绝不说“再次见到你”。在过去的几千年里，人类生活在小型游牧群体中。
Everyone probably knew everyone else. People didn't have the information overload we have today. You and I can come into contact with hundreds, thousands of people in a single day. Our minds simply haven't evolved at the same speed as our societies. There are going to be outliers among us, people with extraordinary skill at recognizing faces. Some of them may end up as security officers, or gregarious socialites, or politicians. The rest of us are going to keep smiling awkwardly at office parties, at people we're supposed to know.
每个人可能都认识其他人。人们没有我们今天所经历的信息过载。你和我可以在单日内与数百、数千人接触。我们的思维进化速度根本跟不上社会的发展。我们当中难免会出现一些异类，也就是在识别人脸方面有着非凡技能的人。他们中的一些人最终可能会成为安保人员、社交名流或政治家。而我们其他人则将在办公室派对上，对那些我们本该认识的人继续尴尬地微笑。
It's what happens when you stumble around in the 21st century with a mind that was designed in the Stone Age. This week's show was produced by Chris Banderer and edited by Jenny Schmidt. Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle, our team includes Raina Cohen, Path Shah, Laura Quarelle, Thomas Liu and Angus Chen. Our unsung hero this week is Alexander Diaz, who troubleshoots technical problems whenever they arise and has the most unflappable, kind disposition in the face of whatever crisis we throw his way. Producers at NPR have taken to calling him Batman because he is constantly, silently, secretly, saving the day.
这就是当你带着一个在石器时代设计的大脑在21世纪跌跌撞撞时会发生的情况。本周的节目由克里斯·班德尔制作，珍妮·施密特剪辑。我们的监督制作人是塔拉·博伊尔，我们的团队包括雷娜·科恩、帕斯·沙、劳拉·夸雷尔、托马斯·刘和安格斯·陈。我们本周的无名英雄是亚历山大·迪亚斯，每当技术问题出现时，他都会进行故障排除，无论我们抛给他什么危机，他总是拥有最镇定、最善良的心态。NPR的制作人们开始叫他“蝙蝠侠”，因为他一直在默默地、秘密地拯救世界。
Thanks Batman. If you liked today's episode, please take a second to share it with a friend. We're always looking for new people to discover our show. I'm Shankar Vedantum, and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢你，蝙蝠侠。如果你喜欢今天的节目，请花一秒钟把它分享给朋友。我们一直在寻找新听众来发现我们的节目。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。这个节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。